hey Dewey Pete Wentz from Fall Out Boy
where no I'm calling stubner from the
band the Dewey Finn experience you kept
the name even after I quit yeah we kept
the name we didn't want to confuse our
fan boy your guitar
I'll take double why this sad spin and
doesn't pay like it used to and lost
kind of a jerk mr. Finn doesn't wanted
that yes I did trust me
this guy trolls a sign for living he'll
take the money I am very good at this he
is he once got me to pay $15 for my own
lunch
deep breath 3 2 1 all right all right
I'll take the original price Oh think
Clapton
now that I've got Joan Jett back we're
gonna crush you at Battle of the Bands
we got a new singer and we're gonna blow
your band away well we got a killer new
singer to name signee I'm saying that
because I'm holding a sign no he or she
is totally real yeah otherwise why would
I be willing to bet Joan Jett we went
battle of the bands
you're on please tell me one of you can
sing and is cool with changing your name
to sign II